the prime minister in northern ireland
on a visit to this belfast defense
factory supplying weapons to ukraine
but while the war in eastern europe
continues so too detentions over trade
closer to home as the prime minister
prepares to scrap parts of the uk brexit
deal we would love
this to be done in a
consensual way
with our friends and partners uh
ironing out the problems uh stopping
some of these these barriers east-west
but to get that done to have the
insurance we need to we need to proceed
with a legislative solution at the same
time
[Music]
a pm determined to drive change but as
he arrived for crisis talks so did his
opponents
and as northern ireland's party leaders
followed him in
what's your message to boris johnson
today the pressure for progress palpable
you need action not words right
but inside not much action meetings last
in just half an hour with very little
unlocked
we've had what we would describe as a
a fairly tough meeting with the prime
minister if the prime minister
introduces legislation overriding the
protocol is that a red line for you
when it comes to power sharing
there is no circumstances we envisage in
which the protocol can be wished away
spirited away or indeed legislated away
the notion that in the mother of all
parliaments as it boasts
that there would be an attempt to
legislate to break international law is
shocking it's breathtaking and i we find
ourselves astounded but for the dup who
want to scrap the northern ireland
protocol hope finally that the pm might
act mrs donaldson um
sinn fein came out and said that it was
a tough meeting you seem
less unhappy are you more hopeful now
we've waited a long time in this moment
we've waited a long time to see the
government bring forward proposals that
represent action
to deal with the problems created by the
rhc border the pm here today because he
wants to try to get the northern ireland
assembly up and running again but this
is a naughty problem the dups boycott
installment until it succeeds in
scrapping that post-brexit customs
border down the irish sea which these
unionists say undermine northern
ireland's place in the uk
but for all the tensions in belfast it's
in brussels where solutions will be
found quite simply the pm is asking the
eu to make further concessions and if he
doesn't get them he's preparing to table
legislation in the house of commons to
unilaterally override some parts of the
brexit deal with all the risk that
entails
the politics of collapsing talks and a
possible eu trade war difficult but so
too are the practicalities for
businesses dealing with more checks and
costs
you're talking about 200 pounds of
pallet coming over you know which you
know it's a that's a lot of money that
and that that money has to be added on
to something it has to be added on to
the consumer i mean yeah i mean i can't
keep on absorbing it all the time you
know
the costs of brexit clear to this trade
and the political cost rise in two mr
johnson determined to break the impasse
but at what price beth rigby sky news
belfast